[Música]
hablamos ahora de economía en france 24
por ello me acompaña en el estudio
daniel hablando con daniela bienvenida
vamos a iniciar hablando de la cepal que
lanzó a sus proyecciones sobre el
impacto de la guerra en ucrania en la
pobreza en américa latina' aparecen dos
temas sumamente distantes pero aquí
estamos con consecuencias que nos
afectan a todos y son consecuencias no
necesariamente directas son
consecuencias indirectas las que remarca
esta comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe que cree que sobre
todo por el encarecimiento de los
precios de la energía y también de los
alimentos pues la pobreza va a subir al
33 7% y la pobreza extrema al 14,9 por
ciento en 2022 esto es entre 1 y 2
puntos porcentuales más de lo que fueron
en 2021 respectivamente ahora miremos en
valentina por países entre los que se
espera un incremento de más de un punto
porcentual en su tasa de pobreza están
méxico colombia brasil y paraguay es
decir ellos son los que más van a
contribuir a que ese 7 sus 78 millones
se sumen a los 86 millones que ya sufren
de inseguridad alimentaria en la región
escuchamos
daniela y en argentina vamos a hablar de
argentina que busca gravar a las
empresas que se han beneficiado
económicamente de la guerra claro el
presidente alberto fernández y su
ministro de economía dieron a conocer
hoy la iniciativa que pretende regular
esa renta adicional que les está
llegando a algunos exportadores y que no
se debe precisamente a un mejoramiento
de su negocio sino a la situación en
ucrania se trata de un impuesto
adicional del 15 por ciento las
ganancias de aquellas empresas que en
2022 tengan una utilidad neta sujeta a
impuestos superior a los mil millones de
pesos estos son más o menos 10 millones
de dólares también que cumplan una de
esas dos condiciones que tengan un
margen de más del 10 por ciento de
ganancias o que vean subir en más del 20
por ciento esas mismas utilidades este
año un ex diputado nos explica que
tramiten espera entonces a este proyecto
el proyecto de ley de renta inesperada
que envió el gobierno argentino al
congreso de la nación para tener un
tratamiento
muy importante y va a tener sus
dificultades porque en la cámara de
diputado a la nación la mayoría la tiene
de la oposición
en la cámara de senadores la tiene
mínimamente el oficialismo ahora quienes
van a ser los grandes actores de toda
esta ley los gobernadores porque todo lo
que se recaude por la ley de renta
inesperada va a ser distribuido
proporcionalmente con las distintas
provincias que integran la nación
argentina un gran debate le espera a
este proyecto de ley
daniela pues sanciones que quieren
implementar los gobiernos internamente
para también no desincentivar esta
cooperación entre las empresas y rusia-
cambiamos ahora hablamos de turquía
ahora turquía que se cambió el nombre y
que seguirá impulsando tasas de interés
más bajas vamos a ver si nos
acostumbramos a ese nombre valentina
pues mire esta es una estrategia muy
poco ortodoxa para frenar una inflación
galopante que en el último año hasta
mayo fue superior al 73 por ciento y le
voy a explicar por qué porque la gran
mayoría de los bancos centrales del
mundo lo que está haciendo es subiendo
las tasas de interés para desincentivar
el consumo de la gente y así controlar
el dramático aumento de los precios pero
turquía lo que ha venido es nadando en
contra de esa corriente y haciendo cada
es más barato el acceso al préstamo con
el propósito de mover la economía y lo
que ha logrado es elevar todavía más los
precios el presidente de recep tayyip
erdogán aseguró este lunes que va a
seguir usando esa estrategia y la moneda
local que se llama la lira siguió
perdiendo valor en medio de una fuerte
crisis monetaria de varios meses pero el
mandatario dice que si no se han notado
los efectos de su política es por la
guerra en ucrania y no porque no
funcione bueno pues será esperar a ver
con qué nos encontramos en unos meses en
este panorama económico vamos con los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
valentina world suite en cerró al alza
sin mayores cambios con excepción del
índice tecnológico nasdaq y es que la
acción de twitter cayó más de un 1 por
ciento después de que el multimillonario
y los más que advirtiera que podría
retirarse de su oferta de 44 mil
millones de dólares para adquirir la red
social américa latina cerró en rojo la
bolsa mexicana como los seis sesiones
seguidas en negativo y entretanto europa
terminó al alza la bolsa de londres
subiendo un 1 por ciento en medio de
toda esta convulsión política por
bolillos daniela a usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación económica ya
continuamos aquí en directo américa con
directo